nous de l'évasion dans une prison
française quatre hommes se sont échappés
cet après midi de la maison d'arrêt de
loos les lille
crise politique en roumanie des milliers
de manifestants assiège le bâtiment du
conseil du front de salut national et
l'élection municipale partielle à cannes
le point sur le taux de participation en
direct dans quelques minutes les plus
beaux essais du championnat de france la
composition de l'équipe de france notre
invité jean baptiste lafond le 19/20
inaugure une page spéciale rugby
bonsoir nouvelles évasions
spectaculaires dans une prison française
à loos-lez-lille cette fois quatre
hommes ont réussi à éviter les coups de
feu les gardiens et à s'enfuir après
avoir escaladé le mur d'enceinte deux
des quatre hommes sont considérées comme
de dangereux criminels
marie-odile panijel 15h15 l'heure de la
promenade dans la cour de loos les lille
six détenus parviennent à tromper la
vigilance des gardiens ils franchissent
de grillages de protection escalade un
premier mur de sécurité
deux d'entre eux n'iront pas plus loin
alors le personnel a réagi très
rapidement puisque l'alarmé a été donnée
de suite et d'autre part au niveau du
mirador le surveillant qui s'y
trouvaient donc attirer un détenu donc
n'a pas réussi à partir il s'est cassé
la jambe en redescendant du mur et un
autre détenu a été arrêté par les
surveillants dans le chemin de ronde et
les quatre autres ont réussi à partie là
ce sont des détenus sains et condamnés
et les trois autres sont les procédures
criminelles sont des gens oui
effectivement dangereux
les quatre évadés ont intercepté une
voiture ait fui en direction
d'armentières au nord de l'île cette
évasion relance la polémique autour de
l'hermétisme des prisons françaises elle
vient s'ajouter à la liste déjà longue
des évasions au cours de ces dernières
semaines commentaire hervé guinaud et de
8 pour l'administration pénitentiaire
l'évasion de la maison d'arrêt de loos
les lille est en effet la dernière d'une
série impressionnante de huit évasion
qui a commencé le 6 décembre 1989 à
lannemezan pour le seul mois de janvier
on enregistre 4 évasion belfort le neuf
un évadé brest le quator deux évadés
périgueux le 18 trois évadés
la progression mathématiques et
d'ailleurs respecté puisque cet après
midi ce sont quatre détenus qui ont
profité de la promenade pour se faire la
belle en décembre ce sont les prisons
demain
doué et lannemezan qui avait enregistré
ce genre de défaillance si le nombre
d'évadés continue à progresser au rythme
actuel 10 pour le seul mois de janvier
on devrait très rapidement dépassé les
chiffres constatés au cours des trois
dernières années
années au cours desquelles on
enregistrait en moyenne 50 évadés chaque
année à l'étranger la crise politique en
roumanie
plusieurs milliers de manifestants
encerclent ce soir le siège du conseil
du front de salut national le président
élie et jusqu'où a même été hué
lorsqu'il s'est présenté au balcon pour
tenter d'apaiser la foule le point de la
situation ce soir avec hélène dhr
impossible de parler
y'en iliescu le président du front de
salut national et hué par des milliers
de manifestants
il doit rentrer dans le bâtiment le
nouveau pouvoir celui de la préssion
chez ce coup n'a plus vraiment
d'autorité il ya quelques instants les
manifestants ont forcé les barrages de
soldats devant le siège du front de
salut national
du haut des blindés ils crient démission
démission à bas le communisme à bas la
dictature
la manifestation d'aujourd'hui est la
plus importante depuis la révolution de
décembre elle a été appelée par
l'opposition parti national paysans en
tête avec le parti social démocrate et
le parti national libéral
les trois organisations réclament la
dissolution du front de salut national
qui s'est autoproclamé gouvernement
provisoire après la chute de la
dictature chaouch et secoue et dont
certains membres sont d'anciens
communistes
l'opposition accuse le front de salut
national de monopoliser le pouvoir et
conteste la décision de présenter les
candidats aux élections générales
prévues en mai prochain
des représentants des trois partis
d'opposition ont été reçus tout à
l'heure par aion iliescu au siège du
front scène nationale il réclame la
formation d'un conseil d'union nationale
et d'un gouvernement de coalition
ouvert à toutes les formations
politiques le gouvernement avait
organisé une contre manifestation
elle n'a réuni que quelques centaines de
personnes et a été totalement noyée par
l'opposition politique en france mise en
garde très claire ce matin de jacques
chirac dans le journal du dimanche le
président du rpr déclare en substance
aux militants on vous cache la vérité où
vous me faites confiance et vous votez
pour la synthèse ou fait un choix
différent et nul ne s'étonnera que j'en
tire donc les conséquences et la menace
du départ reste maintenant la réponse de
charles pasqua jean charles pasqua
invité ce soir du grand jury rtl le
monde
est ce qu'avec monsieur chirac
nous allons continuer un dialogue
concernant seulement la boutique et la
gestion du rpr est ce que monsieur
chirac ne mérite pas et nous aussi
est-ce que nous ne méritons pas de
situer le dialogue un autre niveau
alors il ya une chose que je n'accepte
pas de toutes façons de quiconque
je n'accepte pas comme monsieur chirac
met en doute notre sincérité
nous ne mettons pas en doute la sienne
ne rabaissons pas le débat n'essayons
pas de le ramener à un niveau médiocre
est ce qu'il ne comprend pas qu à
l'heure actuelle philippe seguin et moi
et ceux qui nous entourent nous donnons
l'image de l'ouverture et du progrès et
que ceux qui l'entourent donne
l'impression de la fermeture et du
rétrécissement
alors ma proposition est simple nous
avons encore le temps les assises ont
lieu long de février je demande qu avant
le 11 février à une date qui sera choisi
dans l'ensemble de la france
nos fédérations soient convoqués appelé
à débattre des deux textes en présence
et que ce soit les militants qui vote
politique encore l'association des
démocrates fondée par les ministres de
l'ouverture ou le savait et le mouvement
des radicaux de gauche souhaitent unir
leurs destinées pour tenter de fixer
tous les mitterrandistes non socialiste
et créer ainsi un grand mouvement de
centre-gauche promesse de mariage ce
week-end à paris et rypien les
fiançailles ont eu lieu dans la plus
stricte intimité seulement une centaine
de personnes au premier rang bien sûr
les invités de marque une kyrielle de
ministres dits de l'ouverture lionel
stoléru orange efforts ou hélène dans
lac sont venus témoigner leur
consentement
l'association des démocrates à laquelle
ils appartiennent et le mouvement des
radicaux de gauche ont décidé de s'unir
aujourd'hui tout est prêt mais reste un
petit détail ils ne savent pas encore
sous quel nom
oui nous nous réfléchissons sur le sujet
et nous ne sommes pas encore déterminé
mais je ne pense pas que le nom soit
l'essentiel ce qui est important c'est
la volonté et le contenu
la volonté est de constituer une
confédération à foyer qui pourrait
accueillir d'autres personnalités comme
simone veil des centristes ou encore des
gaullistes de gauche pour fonder la
terre m'a parti de centre gauche
destinée à élargir la majorité
présidentielle un projet qui a
évidemment reçu la bénédiction de
françois mitterrand premier tour de
l'élection municipale partielle
aujourd'hui à cannes après
l'invalidation du maire michel mouillot
qui brigue à nouveau les suffrages de
ses administrés en direct andré
grandissent
quel est le taux de participation le
problème avec cannes
nous n'avons pas la liaison en direct
nous ferons une nouvelle tentative
participation andré grandissent nous
lisez tout à l'heure dans la première
partie de 19 ans estimé à 60% environ
société la mystérieuse disparition de
sheer gazte ni le créateur du mouvement
intégriste la voie de l'islam en france
enlèvement ou simulacre de rap toutes
les hypothèses restent plausibles ce
soir morad aït habbouche sur cette
affiche
farid gap technique qui a disparu
maintenant depuis plus de 48 heures
c'était vendredi le fondateur de la voie
de l'islam a été interpellé avec sa
femme alors qu'il se rendait en voiture
à paris ce sont des hommes qui se sont
présentés comme des policiers ils nous
ont présenté une carte 1 c'est le srpj
lui même qui a dit écoutez jusqu'à
jusqu'à preuve du contraire pour nous
c'est ni des policiers ni pas des
policiers ou srpj de versailles on se
refuse pour le moment à tout commentaire
sur cette enquête
mais en avril 89 au moment de la firme
roche dit farid gamme ceni avait écrit à
françois mitterrand il se sentait menacé
j'affirme que certains services français
et israéliens pas obligatoirement en
coordination prépare mon assassinat dans
les jours les mois ou au maximum les
très prochaines années qui suivent le
sheikh abu falgha teny hygiène hygiène
beaucoup de gens ont de même que la voie
de l'islam disons en france elle dérange
beaucoup sauf surprise quelques instants
avant notre départ le téléphone sonne au
bout du fil les disparus phadia sa femme
avait dit ça ils ont raison ils ont
raccroché
pour être complet sachant encore que
cette association la voie de l'islam a
déposé son bilan la semaine dernière
avec 100 millions de francs de passif
justice
le réseau de poseurs de bombes auteurs
des attentats qui avaient ensanglanté
paris en 1986 neuf hommes une femme
comparaissent à partir de demain devant
le tribunal correctionnel de paris
ultime étape avant les assises rappelle
des heures dramatiques de 1986 clément
weill raynal
de tous les attentats commis en 1986
c'est sans nul doute celui de la rue de
rennes qui est resté le plus présent
dans les mémoires
rappelez vous le 17 septembre 1986 une
bombe de forte puissance placée dans une
poubelle explose en fin d'après midi
devant le magasin tati rue de rennes
sept personnes sont tuées
cinquante et une blessée il s'agit du
plus meurtrier de la longue série
d'attentats commis en france depuis 10
mois de décembre 1985 à septembre 86 15
attentats à l'explosif sont commis dans
la capitale 13 morts plus de 250 blessés
jamais depuis la guerre d'algérie la
france n'avait connu une telle violence
terroriste pendant dix mois en deux
vagues successives des bombes explosent
dans les magasins sur les boulevards
dans les restaurants et les transports
publics trains métros des attentats
aveugles revendiqué depuis beyrouth par
un mystérieux cfppa qui réclame la
libération de trois chefs terroristes
détenus en france par utg hangar
abidjian
georges ibrahim abdallah et anis
naccache septembre 86 le rythme des
attentats s'accélère en une semaine cinq
bombes les plus violentes explose à
paris faisant 11 morts et 160 blessés
puis après le massacre de la rue de
rennes les attentats s'arrête sans que
l'on sache vraiment pourquoi
six mois plus tard au printemps 87 coups
de filets de la dst les membres du
réseau dirigé par fouad ali saleh sont
arrêtés dix d'entre eux reconnaissent
leurs liens avec les terroristes du
hezbollah pro iranien
reste que l'on ignore jusqu'à
aujourd'hui les mobile exact de cette
vague d'attentats le procès qui s'ouvre
demain permettra peut-être de savoir
précisément pourquoi un ou plusieurs
états du proche orient ont décidé en
1986 de mettre paris à feu et à sang
l'autre fait marquant de l'actualité en
france et à l'étranger commentaires
sophie guillou le pc colonne est au
coeur de la tourmente ce week-end des
divisions sont apparues au sein des
délégués réunis en congrès pour fonder
un nouveau parti de gauche
le réformiste thaddeus fisbach souhaite
créer une union sociale-démocrate qui
rompre radicalement avec l'ancien parti
ils menacent de faire scission entre 6
et 12 morts des dizaines de blessés
c'est le bilan des manifestations qui
ont enflammé plusieurs villes du kosovo
hier depuis quelques jours la tension
monte dans cette province yougoslave la
population albanaise protestent contre
les discriminations dont elle fait
l'objet aujourd'hui de nouvelles
manifestations ont été dispersées
premier test électoral aujourd'hui pour
le chancelier kohl avant les
législatives de décembre prochain les
électeurs de la sarre se sont vendus aux
urnes pour choisir leurs députés au
parlement régional selon les premières
estimations de la télévision allemande
oskar lafontaine le candidat de
l'opposition obtiendrait la majorité
absolue
la tente toujours au port du guilvinec
le chalutier lafayette reste introuvable
le bateau n'a pas donné de nouvelles
depuis jeudi dernier
les recherches continuent mais devrait
être compliqués par les conditions météo
cinq ans de prison avec sursis pour jean
schmitt deux ans avec sursis pour
christophe garcia la cour d'assises de
paris a rendu hier son verdict dans le
procès oussékine un verdict discuté
plusieurs associations le jugent trop
clément sos racisme a appelé à un
rassemblement de protestation retour à
l'actualité politique premier tour de
l'élection municipale partielle
aujourd'hui à cannes andrée grandissent
en direct de cannes alors a t'on
maintenant quelques informations plus
précises sur ce que sera le taux de
participation se déprécie c'est très
difficile à dire cela dit vous avez
souligné que c'était une élection
partielle
donc si je vous dis que à peu près à 19
heures ont pensé à 60% de participation
c'est pas mal du tout parce que souvenez
ou clermont ferrand au premier tour a
fait que 23% donc 60% pour cannes c'est
pas mal du tout c'est quand même une
élection un petit peu différent de 89
puisque en 89 il y avait cinq candidats
je vous disais tout à l'heure
cette année il y en a sept les trois
nouveaux si jacques d'auzole rpr qui
part donc sans le soutien du rpr albert
perron du front national est un nouveau
venu paul vogel écologistes et michel
mouillot bien sûr le maire invalidé se
représente il est p r jean bernard
pinaud ex du front national dissidents
du front national lui fait une si une
viste seul en lire aussi et donc
ghislaine picot 4048 1279 électeurs vont
donc décidé de l'élection du maire après
une campagne mouvementée qui a été
marquée par des rebondissements
spectaculaires des alliances et puis du
retrait de soutien de démission je vous
rappelle que l'année dernière donc
monsieur michel mouillot l'avait emporté
avec 41 points 44% des voix
je ne peux pas vous donner des chiffres
beaucoup plus précis je vous retrouverai
à 22h avec la des chiffres réels et
officiels merci en vrai 22h15 même
peut-être les premiers résultats dans
soir 3 les sports maintenant avec le
football et les surprises du 8e tour de
la coupe de france
abbeville et grenoble club de deuxième
division éliminés par des équipes
hiérarchiquement inférieures grenoble
nous allons y revenir dans un instant
avec daniel lauclair
voici tout de suite quelques-uns des
plus beau but du 8e tour alain de
relance c'est un secret de polichinelle
8e le tour est une échéance redouté pour
les clubs de division 2 et pourtant pas
de surprise enregistrée
alès vêtus de bleu s'est imposé à
blagnac par mbow les qui reprend au
deuxième poteau un centre venu de la
gauche
1 0 pour les cévenols toujours
l'infinitésimal écart pour bové les
picards en rouge ont dû attendre les
cinq dernières minutes pour inscrire le
but de la victoire par l'intermédiaire
de motards avalanche de buts la rochelle
autre danger qui ouvre la marque sur
penalty ce n'est la grange égalisation
de la rochelle parfait jouant d'un tir
croisé les charentes et vont prendre
l'aventage sur ce tir lobé de kilos dès
lors les angevins affirment leur
suprématie moulin de l'extérieur du pied
remis les deux équipes à égalité 1 but
de raccroc de la grange permet angers de
mener au score
la victoire viendra irréfutable par ce
but de la tête de cabanel 4 à 2 pour
angers la coupe est pleine
enfin le match des chefs opposant
guingamp et le havre appartenant la
division 2 les normands pluraliste vont
l'emporter
le seul but de la rencontre sera leur
vaut de l'onu d'un tir de 25 m les
havrais qualifier alors un autre duel
entre équipes de deuxième division cet
après-midi nancy a frôlé le pire face à
dijon commentaires de rémy woody
szczesny les nas est en lente échappé
belle cet après-midi sur le terrain des
dijonnais gorgée d'eau c'est bien
steffen qui ouvre le score pour nancy à
la 29e minute mais il faut vite je lui
réponds juste après la mi temps
il faudra ensuite attendre les
prolongations pour voir le dijonnais
test a raté un penalty avant que les
nancéens ne s'impose de justesse par 7
tirs au but à 6 le leader du groupe a de
deuxième division a eu chaud
on verra voilà daniel lauclair reste
maintenant l'un des éliminés du jour
c'est l'équipe de grenoble on en a pas
parlé pour l'instant battu à ajaccio
dans des conditions qui paraissent
invraisemblables à ce niveau c'est moins
qu'on puisse dire aventure peu banale
pour l'équipe de grenoble qui se
déplaçait donc à ajaccio rendez vous
compte oublie de licences et de surcroît
trois titulaires qui n'avait pas non
plus leur carte d'identité
résultat les grenoblois ont joué tout le
match à 10 contre 11 le gardien
titulaire stéphane d'angelo temps à
regarder
il a fait à regarder jouer ses copains
sur le banc de touche conséquence
ajaccio club de d3 gagne et élimine donc
grenoble 2 à 0 une étourderie qui coûte
cher carton rouge au dirigeant de
renault et saluons quand même la
performance de ceux d'en face à 11 voire
d'avril sedan équipe de troisième
division
aviles club de deuxième division reste
thouaré le petit club promotionnaire que
nous avions choisi de suivre plus
particulièrement il n'y a pas eu de
miracle face au football club de tours
le tout sous le regard attentif de jean
philippe guillin et christophe airaud
ambiance garantie at war et 5000
habitants pour accueillir tour ils
étaient près de 2000 massés autour des
balustrades 2000 à croire fermement aux
chances des locaux en bleu mais ce sont
les tourangeaux qui ouvre très
rapidement le score sur une tête de leur
avant-centre dominguez tristesse dans le
stade et six tours infligé une véritable
correction au petit poucet les jeunes
thouaréens à décontracter enchaîne
quelques bons mouvements dans ses buts
yann loarec se ressaisit et multiplie
les arrêts réflexes et à la mi-temps
tour ne mène que par 1 à 0 contre
lorient les avait marqué un but comme ça
au début et puis à la fin est bas et
thouaré avait gagné dehors je crois que
ils peuvent encore faire un peu tête
égalisant minutes historique pour
thouaré pendant 60 secondes
les amateurs auteur d'un superbe but
vont revenir à égalité avec les
professionnels avant de s'écrouler en
fin de rencontre sur deux contre
attaques assassines tour s'impose 3 1 le
rêve de poids et s'achève mais tous les
joueurs locaux peuvent quitter le
terrain la tête haute
on n'est pas ridicule on les a fait
souffrir c'est ce qu'on voulait au moins
c'est à dire quand même ça va vite on
n'est pas vide face rythme là vous
oublierai jamais ce match
non je n'oublierai jamais mes doigts 40
ans gilles passera encore
le rugby maintenant le match du jour
c'était incontestablement aujourd'hui
agen béziers les essais de cet
après-midi les plus beaux en tout cas
commentaires à l'indolence agen béziers
une affiche qui reste toujours fidèle à
son identité de rugby panache la preuve
aujourd'hui sur un stade transformé en
bourbier plus propice à la pratique d'un
rugby pourcentage que le jeu de
mouvement les deux formations ont écarté
les ballons plutôt que de cadenasser la
rencontre
résultat un rugby d'envergure les
agenais parviendront à concrétiser leur
domination par des coups de pied arrêtés
le premier réussi par tampon qui va
récidiver et qui permet à son équipe de
mener 6-0
le match va hélas dégénéré ces gestes en
pays du pruneau sont qualifiés les
castagnes finalement agen s'impose sur
ses terres 9 0 avec le point
d'interrogation subsiste et blanc' ou
sera-t-il remis de sa blessure oui mais
son équipe a été battue par bègles sur
un essai de moscato 13 0 toulon de son
côté poursuit son bonhomme de chemin
pas de détails devant nîmes 18,9 et deux
essais à son actif
voilà daniel lauclair et c'est de blanco
ce qui explique l'absence de jean
baptiste lafond il nous avait promis
d'être notre invité ce soir en direct de
toulouse jean-baptiste lafond n'est pas
là car il ne fait plus partie du tout de
l'équipe de france en effet partant du
principe qu'on ne révolutionne pas une
équipe qui gagne mais que l'on peut tout
fait y apporter quelques retouches
le comité de sélection avec jacques faut
bien sûr n'a pas révolutionné cette
équipe de france que vous découvrez
maintenant sur le tableau deux joueurs
qui étaient à cardiff contre le pays de
galles ont perdu leur place didier
camberabero est remplacé par franck
mesnel au poste de demi d'ouverture et
jean baptiste lafond vous venez de le
dire cette sa place à l'arrière à serge
blanco voilà les deux modifications pour
l'équipe de france qui va donc affronter
samedi prochain au parc des princes
l'équipe de la rose le quinze
d'angleterre
alors on comprend le retour de serge
blanco dans la mesure où c'est
effectivement un joueur qui a beaucoup
apporté à l'équipe de france franck mais
elle a été écarté pour cause de tournée
plus ou moins licites passionné par son
club le racing parce qu'il avait pris
quelques libertés quelques vacances en
uruguay ça n'avait pas plu aux
dirigeants du racing qui l'avait
sanctionné et donc jacques fouroux avait
respecté cette sanction maintenant la
sanction est élevé il peut donc
réintégrer le 15 francs et puis non
dron pas jean baptiste lafond
probablement très triste de ne pas
participer à cette finale avant la
lettre entre l'équipe de france et
l'angleterre samedi prochain au parc des
princes daniel un mot maintenant de ce
qui a été
j'allais dire l'événement hippique de
l'année l'événement hippique de
l'après-midi territoire pour asie tout à
fait hors asie le cheval du siècle
n'ayons pas peur des mots
il entre dans la légende en remportant
son quatrième prix d'amérique se trouve
qu'un photon n'avait réussi avant lui
ourasi pour sa dernière course est sorti
par la grande porte et j'en suis sûr
qu'au moment où il a réalisé cet exploit
dans les tribunes jean rené gougeon qui
vous le savez l'an passé avait eu une
attaque cardiaque il était donc en
spectateur dans les tribunes c'est lui
qui durant toute sa carrière a jalonné
ce poulain ce cheval d'exception ourasi
je suis sûr qu'à ce moment là jean rené
a écrasé une petite larme alors
quatrième victoire donc dur asie c'est
la dernière le roi du trot faisait ses
adieux à la compétition aujourd'hui en
tout cas c'est mieux dans l'histoire
j'ai regardé mes fiches que bellino 2
que roquépine mêmes uranie c'était dans
les années 25 26 27 vous dépanner pour
terminer ce journal une voie unique
celle de teresa berganza l'une des plus
célèbre mezzo soprano dans un récital le
30 janvier à la salle pleyel à paris
avec l'ensemble orchestral de paris
dominique poncet est allé la surprendre
au milieu de sa répétition
quand une des plus grandes divas du
monde répète un récital salle pleyel
sous la baguette arturo tamayo et qu
elle s'assied sur le sol de la scène
soudainement enfantine malicieuse par
volubile bien ici michel que je veux
parce que je mens manie toujours là avec
d'été avec les pastilles avec tout et
son angoisse à lui mais il mérite
et si je suis seul mais je suis
complètement seul
qu'est ce que vous avez dans votre
portefeuille à mes cordes vocales mais
l'effet regardé par par mes enfants qui
ne seraient pas très bien avec le king
edward la routine et la langue mais les
libraires avec les lumières et on peut
voir naturellement je peux pas les voir
comme
mon docteur mais si j'ai pu savoir déjà
six étapes et rose ont gonflé quand j'ai
commencé à chanter je suis allé voir
adopter pour la première fois je lui dis
parce que maintenant poursuivre envoyés
et il m'a dit vous savez vous commencer
car il est difficile parce que vous
commenciez que la tarir du silence
ces six mois je n'ai chante un avis
c'est votre faute
parce qu'ils l'ont été par les boulons
alors c'était comment
enfin cette édition je vous retrouve à
22h15 pour soir 3 très bonne soirée à
tous